what's up everybody in case you don't
know who our next guest is you would
definitely know who he is after this
episode Saki Aviv is a partner at sure
my f guys Marin Aviv and has done some
of the most iconic logos on planet Earth
logos like PBS chase mobile Showtime and
Nat Geo just to name a few
on this episode sake aviv has given us
the most definitive answer as to what
makes for a good and consequently a bad
logo and the answer surprised all of us
so you people think a love we should say
a whole lot about us all of us should be
pretty
or lovers should you know we should love
our logo or actually all these are not
not true at all a good logo really
there's three things that it needs to be
needs to be appropriate distinctive and
memorable and then it needs to be simple
super super simple by appropriate that
doesn't mean expressive she didn't try
to say a whole lot it should just be
appropriate in the feeling so it's like
a personality thing it's a core idea and
the feeling of it so if it's in in sport
maybe it's bold and dynamic if it's in
fashion maybe it's elegant it's a
feeling the second one is that it'll be
distinctive and memorable circle unusual
enough to persist in our mind we see it
once or twice you can describe it to
somebody but do the lid on a piece of
paper that's a good test the third one
maybe the most important one it needs to
be simple super super simple
so it can be reproduced everywhere in
tiny sizes and pixel formats and so on
because the answer to what is a bad logo
is something that looks generic is a bad
logo on the one hand and on the other
hand something that's too complicated is
the bad logo because it's gonna fall
apart in small sizes and pixel formats
and so on
that's the the magic is finding that
balance between something simple and
something distinctive and when we strike
that balance you know we found the right
solution you know the one the one that
we will push for let us know what your
top three criteria are for what makes
for a great logo and while you're at it
let us know what your favorite logos of
all time are don't forget to Like
comment and subscribe and hit that Bell